you uh like I mentioned with with SpaceX
you give a lot of people hope and a lot
of people look up to you millions of
people look up to you uh if we think
about young people
in high school maybe in college
um what advice would you give to them
about
if they want to try to do something big
in this world they want to really have a
big positive impact what advice would
you give them about their career maybe
about life in general
try to be useful
um you do things that are useful to your
fellow human beings to the world it's
very hard to be useful
um
very hard
um you know are you contributing more
than you
consume you know like uh
like can you
try to have a positive net contribution
to society
um
I think that's the thing to aim for you
know not not to try to be sort of a
leader for
for the sake of being a leader or
whatever
um
a lot of times people who if a lot of
times the people you want as leaders are
are the people who don't want to be
leaders
so
um
if you live a useful life
that is a good life
a life worth
having lived
um you know and I like I said I would I
would encourage people to
I use the mental tools of physics and
apply them broadly in life there are the
best tools when you think about
education and self-education what do you
recommend so there's the university
there is
a self-study
there is uh Hands-On sort of finding a
company or a place or a set of people
that do the thing you're passionate
about and joining them as early as
possible
um there's uh taking a road trip across
Europe for a few years and writing some
poetry which uh which which trajectory
do you suggest
in terms of learning about how you can
become useful as you mentioned how you
can have the most positive impact
what I encourage people to read a lot of
books just read like basically try to
ingest as much information as you can
uh and try to also just develop a good
general knowledge
um
so so you at least have like
a roughly of the land of the the
knowledge landscape
um like try to learn a little about
about a lot of things
um because you might not know what
you're really interested how would you
know what you're really interested in if
you at least aren't like doing it
peripheral exploration and broadly of
of
the knowledge landscape
um
and you talk to people from different
walks of life and different uh
Industries and professions and skills
and occupations like just try you know
learn as much as possible
Man's Search for meaning
isn't the whole thing a search for
meaning
is yeah what's the meaning of life and
all you know but just generally like I
said I would encourage people to read
broadly
um in many different subject areas
um
and and and then try to find something
where there's an overlap of your talents
and and what you're interested in so
people may be good at something but
although they may have skill at a
particular thing but they don't like
doing it
um
so you want to try to find a thing where
you have your that's a good a good uh
combination of of your of the things
that you're inherently good at but you
also like doing
um
and um and reading is a super fast
shortcut to to figure out which where
are you you both good at it you like
doing it and it will actually have
positive impact but you got to learn
about things somehow So reading
a broad range it's just a really read it
you know more important was that kid I I
read through the encyclopedia uh so
that's pretty helpful
um
and uh
also things I didn't even know existed a
lot so obviously it's like as broad as
it gets it's like creators were
digestible I think uh you know whatever
40 years ago
um
so
um you know maybe read through the the
condensed version of the Encyclopedia
Britannica I'd recommend that
um you can always like skip subjects
though you read a few paragraphs and you
know you're not interested just jump to
the next one
that's a read encyclopedia
skim through it
um
and um
but I you know I put a lot of stock in
certainly have a lot of respect for
someone who puts in an honest day's work
uh to do useful things
and and just generally to have like not
a zero-sum mindset
um or or like have have more of a
grow the pie mindset like the
if you sort of say like when when we see
people like have some including some
very smart people
kind of taking an attitude of like like
doing things that seem like morally
questionable
it's often because they have at a base
sort of axiomatic level a zero-sum
mindset
um and and they without realizing it
they don't realize they have a zero sum
mindset or at least that they don't
realize it consciously
um and so if you have zero Sun mindset
then the only way to get ahead is by
taking things from others
if it's like if if the if the pie is
fixed then the only way to have more pie
is to take someone else's pie
but but this is false like obviously the
pie has grown dramatically over time the
economic pie
so the real in reality you can have that
so overuse this analogy if you have a
lot of there's a lot of pie
yeah it's not fixed
um uh so you really want to make sure
you don't you're not operating
um without realizing it from a zero-sum
mindset where where the only way to get
ahead is to take things from others then
that's going to result in you try to
take things from others which is not not
good it's much better to work on
uh uh adding to the economic pie you
know so
quick creating
like I said creating more than you
consume uh doing more than you yeah um
so that that's a big deal um I think
there's like you know Fair number of
people in
in finance that uh do have a bit of a
zero-sum mindset I mean it's all walks
of life I've seen that one of the one of
the reasons
uh Rogan inspires me is he celebrates
all there's a lot there's not not
creating a constant competition like if
there's a scarcity of resources what
happens when you celebrate others and
you promote others the ideas of others
it it uh it actually grows that pie I
mean it every like the uh the resource
the resources become less scarce and
that that applies in a lot of kinds of
domains it applies in Academia where a
lot of people are very uh see some
funding for academic research is
zero-sum and it is not if you celebrate
each other if you make if you get
everybody to be excited about AI about
physics above mathematics I think it
there'll be more and more funding and I
think everybody wins yeah that applies I
think broadly
uh yeah yeah exactly